[音楽]
こんにちははず3世津翁ですようやく皆
さんに報告打ってきますはい以前動画です
ねあの危険すぎるとなぜかというと
エアコンがないでや子が来そうして冷房が
つかないとこの夏の暑い時期暑くて暑くて
進めないよーって話をしてたんですけども
ようやくこちらの
日焼けの跡や箱恋留学の過ぎてから
ようやくアップデート完了しました肇社長
のさあおく
いや違いますさあを組ん
3000万円の家
紹介していきたいとおもいます外装はパッ
と見でぜんぜん変化はないと思うんです
けども本会のアップデートですねどっちか
というとなんかですねもちろんエアコン
空調だけではありません諸々の
アップデート含めると目3000万円
くらいかけて進化しておりますちょうど
アップデートされたらお腹を紹介しながら
見ていきたいと思いますでは以降
1組
愛という気で早速3県のうち見てあ失礼し
ましたさあ奥3000万円のうち見ていき
ましょう今日の旅のナビゲーターは後ろの
スーパーゴリラコング候補ですよろしくお
願いしますよろしくお願い致します今回も
否定しないとおっ
てみましょうありがとうございますま
エアコンがヤバいっていう動画を出したん
ですけどももちろんエアコンがな夫ぐらい
でメインにはしないんですよあたりめ者に
空中を直すのも相当お金かかったんです
けどももっと目に見て分かりやすく
アップデートされているので見ていこうと
思いますじゃあ行きましょうか
もうわかる
もうもう買っちゃいますこれで
こちらどうぞ
そして同入った瞬間の温度
はいまずですね玄関暗かったと思うんです
けどもご覧ください照明つけました
めっちゃ辛くないですかなんか実は前の
玄関があったらここ全部コンクリートの
天井だったんですけどもさすがに暗かった
のでもしっかりと勝目つけさせてもらい
ました5歳1個の欠点来たが
youtube でとけばくらいとどうし
ても見づらかったりするんでもうしっかり
とアップデートしましたここらへんの年間
照明塔も全部明るくしてやっております
素晴らしいアップロードです
そしてこの暗すぎた廊下みてください
くどーなってる
明るえっガーってめっちゃ来なかった
ダウン
前までこれをマジであんな来なかったら
多くが今やご覧くださいこれ
こんな開かなくなってしまいましたトウ
ヨっ
スムースで足のという別の家だよね
ちょっと怖かったじゃないか雑感ダークと
いうかおしゃれな感じだったんですけど今
はもうこんな軽くどこでさとしても顔が
くっきり見えておりますそしてエアコンが
なかったこの廊下も今や珠洲市でここだけ
じゃないんですよ
に帰ってみましょう
10倍彼が今回色々手伝ってくれません
手配するがあれば電話してませんなぜか
ありがとうねー
全然ありがとう第4巻あれど
なにせの
ああ
というで2階でございます2回も3決定
いろいろあったと思うんですよぴくすぎる
照明頭に何かだったか
脳振盪後しますて重視は我々すぐおしゃれ
だったし暗い雰囲気の素敵な2回だったん
ですけどもチェッカーでと改造させて
いただきました
以上ぞ
亡くなったし上みてくださいここ体育館で
ほぼ明るくね
マジカルやばいよねでここに者あった
じゃん低いやつちゃんと移植してこっち側
のあのはしての方に付けさせて頂きまし
たーこっち
も暗かった邪魔しようやくはしても光がと
思ったんでどうですか
明るい末だってめっちゃ来ないよね
何なだ俺ここでにとってもいいんじゃない
か g 尽きる
ここ位
ちょっと密着なかったじゃんここ
そうね多すぎただこれ普通に暗くしたい
ときはオサレな照明だけ消すこともでき
ますしここのラインだけ消したりもでき
ます
ここだけ消すとちょっとまたオシャレだね
もともとこういうクラスだったもんねどう
やってこの天井に照明てきたこれ体育館
四方坦懐にもこの照明関係してるんで3回
もすごいですよ
ご覧くださいさっきの2階の天井の照明が
ここにあるのでここが結構明るいですよね
ここで聴講できると
ほら
消したりー
めっちゃわかるだけど相当
[音楽]
あ
知恵ちゃったこの廊下で甘辛く撮影できる
ということでいまや
この3受けの打つ
資格なしです照明に関しては結構やばかっ
たさんも取れないみたいな場所による暗
すぎて他にもう4回とか他の部屋とか
いろんな照明空調エアコン全て完備されて
おりますその結果
かさんいらっしゃいました全部敗戦から
退いたから光とかのなかったらてんぞに
この戦みたいなこういうのもの頃を加味し
たりすると相当業者さんに萌え据えて
いただいて渦に撮影し提出撮影スタジオと
してはかなり完成に近づいたかなと思い
ます良いですので完成していく動画撮っ
てるんで結構あの近所で動画撮ってるん
ですけどもおっとっとやっぱねぇ
お家へがでかいとそういう修理と改造
かなりお金がかかることが分かりました
一瞬で3000万円ぶっ飛んだねちょっと
内訳見ていきましょうどうしたら30枚か
買ったのかという普通車エアコン付ける
だけそんな何千万円かかるとかおかしいと
思うんですけど家の根本的な原理から改造
しているのでそれくらいお金がかかって
ます4桁の県のお家の修復費の位置なん
です空調エアコンとかですね1400万円
かかっております
あってん400万顔や今ならエアコンで方
金かかってます昔動画でダスっていた際
ですかの田恵とかなんかエアコン代が
めっちゃ高いみたいなウン十万取られてて
なんかそもそもちょっと修理が必要だっ
たりお金がかかるようなシステムになって
たんですけどもそもそも全部変えて風邪の
システム自体大幅に改善させて頂いた結果
まあ1400マンから語ったわけですただ
そのおかげでもうほぼおうちの中全部
涼しいですよー約3億円の家っぽくになり
ましたそしてあの照明大押されぬ落ち着い
た照明がの撮影用の赤レーション2回別
トータル80万円ぐらいかかっております
なんか思っ
たより安いって思ったけど高いですねたら
も youtube にとっては宮里がが
軽さがすごい大事だと思うのでここはもう
もっとお金もかけていいかなとは思ってい
ます続いてセキュリティ実は防犯カメラの
数帳増やしました alsok もば2
教科書したセキュリティその結果へと
473万円は約500万だね約500万円
かてますなんかセキュリティ青とかなあっ
たんですけど死ぬほど強化させていただき
ましたまあといろいろあるんですよねお
部屋のリノベーションえっとカーツ給水
ポンプ交換しよくわかんないけど200万
ぐらいかかってますね受水槽取り替え
20万円ず思想ってなんだあっから
サービスの種類水4万円でまだ治ってない
んですけどエレベーターをついてて
エレベーターの修理は9月中には出来る
みたいですそれがまあ発表不満を超えて
ますねそして今日までトータルで3億円の
を打つにさらに3000万円以上のお金を
ぶっこんで無事今のまだエレベーターとか
できないですけども生活するには申し分
ない空間でようやくできました
やがっもう何回さんを献納を移り住めばせ
みたいな動画を出したことか分時代が高い
とが世代が高いと彼ら金がなくて死ぬとか
ネットが切断されるとか数々の困難を
乗り越えてようやくこの夏3000万円
ぶっこんだ結果どうかが取れる素敵な状態
には仕上がったのかなと思います全然
まだまだ回答していくつもりです屋上は
まずでつくる機です4回のように屋上作り
たいですあとなんかそもそもこの建物自体
がなが全力をあげるために何か電源の改造
とかあとネットの環境強化ですねネット
もっと強くしたいと思ってそこもお金かけ
たいと思ってますあぁちょっとまだ言え
ないですよ徐々に出していくんですけども
もっともっと解説していきます俺はねこの
さあ県の米遊び尽くすよ僕はまだそうだね
3000松島しません立ったからにはもう
惜しみなく自分が[ __ ]く行く大内にし
たいと思ってますああ
若かったなぁ本当に約1年かけてようやく
形になったって感じですねあの
おそらくです分かりませんまた動画だすか
も知れませんもう内にすみませんみたいな
動画件増え約を持ついたし電気も点いて
いる綴じ本的には困ることはないのかなと
思いますけどもヒョッこちらマジでヤバい
事が起きたらの動画に出しますけど
ようやく形になっってかなと思いますまあ
3県のうち全然まだまだ改造していくので
その都度は何か大きな変化があったり今
これはみんなで紹介したいなっていうのが
あったら動画に立っていきたいと思って
おりますので是非今後ともはじめ雪を
そして大0-5-3県大津の新刊楽しみに
して行ってくださいあっ
チャンネル登録お願いしますね全然もっと
持って俺はこの会で遊び尽くしたいと思う
で是非お楽しみに以上あずみ者とでした
じゃんあっ8月なるべく動画だします
[音楽]
eleanor